hi i'm priyanka vergaria a developer
advocate for google cloud and in this
video i will unbox google cloud for you
let's say you are a cloud architect for
food.com how would you build food.com on
google cloud
there are many different ways of
achieving the same goal and no one way
is right or wrong let's use this example
to unbox google cloud and to see some of
the approaches by the end of this demo
you will understand how to navigate the
google cloud console and locate
components needed to build any common
application such as compute storage
database options and more such things
alright let's get started
first things first if you're logged in
to the console for the first time create
a project
a project is required to use google
cloud and forms the basis for creating
enabling and using all the google cloud
services
i'm going to use this one for our demo
today
on the left navigation select billing
and link your billing account
you can go to billing anytime for an
accurate up-to-date picture of your
cloud spend
you can view all products and learn more
about them read documentation
work on a quick start
and even navigate to the individual
products
if you prefer to use the command line
interface from the top right corner you
can activate cloud shell which is an
online terminal preloaded with utilities
such as the g-cloud command line tool
cube cdl and more
now that we know how to navigate through
the console let's look into unboxing a
generic internet-facing application
foo.com on google cloud
first you need a virtual private cloud
vpc network which provides managed
networking functionality for all our
google cloud resources
you can see one created here called
funet with an automatic subnet
inside this network we will create our
application infrastructure
for our app infrastructure the web and
app servers we have multiple options
depending on different factors your
options are cloud run app engine
kubernetes engine compute engine and
anthos
if i choose to deploy serverless
then it means more time spent coding and
less time spent worrying about
infrastructure and scaling now cloudrun
offers the ability to run serverless
containers and app engine is a managed
app platform
if we want to run containerized apps but
with more configuration and flexibility
then we would pick gke
it helps us deploy containerized apps
with kubernetes without much of a
learning curve while giving us the
control over the configuration of nodes
we want in our infrastructure
gke also offers autopilot for when you
need the flexibility and control but
have limited ops and engineering support
for an application in hybrid and
multi-cloud platform use anthos
the maximum control option is compute
engine it is straight up virtual
machines so we can define the
configuration of our machines depending
on the amount of memory and cpu we need
but this control also means more
responsibility to scale manage patch and
maintain them as needed
in this demo we chose compute engine for
our web and application server now let's
see how we set up compute engine to
globally auto scale our food.com service
we will see an instance template which
we call foo template
instance templates are saved virtual
machine configurations used to create
identical vms
we need a template because we need the
service to be created in multiple parts
of the world as needed
in this template you can see the type of
machine
networking storage
disk information and any custom metadata
we can either create these identical vms
individually or as a part of managed
instance groups
here you can also see that this instance
template is used by three managed
instance groups
if you click on any of them or navigate
to instance groups on the left you will
see all the managed instance groups in
three different zones asia europe and
auto
u.s
is set to http load balancing
utilization of 80
which brings me to our load balancing
load balancers distribute traffic to the
servers they can be applied to both
external web servers and internal
application servers under network
services you will see load balancing
here we have created a load balancer
with our three instance groups as
backends
while setting and data in this video may
be different from the demo project the
concepts and guidance apply
cloud load balancing is a fully
distributed and software defined system
it can literally respond to over
millions queries per second and is based
on any cast ip address
what does that mean
well it means that we can define our
front-end infrastructure with a single
ip address and our global users coming
from asia u.s and europe will be served
their request from a server that is as
close to them as possible this is what
our service looks like behind that
single load balancing ip address
it also offers internal load balancing
for our internal application servers and
offers layer 4 tcp and udp load
balancing right at the load balancer we
have an option to enable cloud cdn to
cache the frequently requested media and
web content closer to the user at the
nearest edge location this reduces
latency and optimizes for last mile
performance for our users it also saves
cost by fielding the request right at
the edge without needing to send to the
back end
and cloud cdn would be caching content
stored in cloud storage are object store
where we store all of our media assets
css javascript basically everything
static in nature this means that the
image we used on our web page is being
served from cash
while we are on the topic of network
services cloud dns is google's
infrastructure for high volume
authoritative dns serving which offers
100
sla meaning it never goes down
it uses our global network for anycast
name servers to serve the dns zones from
redundant locations around the world
providing high availability and low
latency for the users
the foo.com might have some media
processing functions for processing
images and video files it can be
deployed on cloud functions which is a
serverless function as a service that
scales as needed and can be triggered
via http cloud storage and other
services for asynchronous messaging
services we would use pub sub send
messages to a topic and service could
subscribe to that topic to receive those
messages and send out the notifications
[Music]
now coming to databases we have a few
choices here for relational databases we
have cloud sql and spanner which are
both managed for generic sql needs mysql
postgres and sql server cloud sql is
perfect spanner is best for massive
scale relational databases that need
horizontal scaling it also supports
strong consistency and acid transactions
i would say you use spanner when you
need the benefits of both relational and
non-relational databases
for non-relational databases we've got
three major options firestore bigtable
and memory store
now firestore is a serverless document
database that can be used as
db as a service easy to set up and
provides fast results to complex queries
in real time
it also supports offline data and syncs
which make it a great choice for mobile
use cases along with web iot and gaming
bigtable on the other hand is a wide
column nosql database that supports
heavy reads and writes with extremely
low latency
this makes it a perfect choice for
events time series data from iot devices
click streams ad events fraud
recommendations and other
personalization related use cases
memory store is a fully managed
in-memory data store service for redis
and memcached at google cloud it is best
for in-memory and transient data stores
offers extremely low latency and high
performance memory store is great for
web and mobile gaming leaderboards
social chats and newsfeed type
applications that require in-memory
database caches as well next part of the
puzzle is analytics we usually have
real-time and batch data to ingest
real-time data could be content from
servers such as click stream data or
from iot device sensors
batch data could be from your logs now
these are obviously just examples once
the data is ingested we process an
enricher to clean it up and make it
ready for downstream systems then store
it in a data warehouse for further
analysis
data warehouse is a storage where you
keep processed data
data analysts then analyze the data and
create dashboards for broader
consumption data scientists can pick up
that data from the data warehouse and
use it for creating machine learning
models to generate predictions you could
also directly ingest data from storage
systems for ml models
we can ingest the batch data from cloud
storage and real-time data from
applications using pubsub which is a
serverless messaging service that scales
to ingest millions of events per second
now data flow can then be used for
processing and enriching the batch and
streaming data it's based on open source
apache beam if you are in the hadoop
ecosystem then use dataproc it is
managed hadoop and spark platform that
is set up to analyze the data faster
instead of worrying about managing and
standing up your own hadoop cluster it
literally spins up a cluster in 90
seconds
bigquery is a serverless data warehouse
that can also act as long-term storage
and a data lake
we can run sql queries to analyze our
data within bigquery and it literally
queries over petabytes of data and
responds in seconds due to the
underlying separation of storage and
compute which is unique to bigquery
we can use this data from bigquery to
create a dashboard in looker and data
studio it also offers machine learning
capabilities so we can create machine
learning models and make predictions by
just writing some sql statements
now for ml and ai projects we can use
the data in bigquery or cloud storage to
train our models in vertex ai or we can
import our media files image and other
unstructured data from cloud storage as
well
machine learning and ai our options
depend on whether we want to create our
own custom model or use a pre-trained
model my recommendation is to always
start with a pre-trained model see if it
works for your use case the most common
use cases are all covered including
images text video and tabular data
if a pre-trained model does not work for
your use case
then use the auto ml model in vertex ai
to train a custom model on your own data
set automl supports all the common use
cases you can evaluate the model and
look at metrics to improve your model it
deploys the model for you and provides
you with an api endpoint
in case you have lots of machine
learning and data science expertise
in-house that is only when i would say
write your own custom model code in the
framework of your choice such as
tensorflow torch and then train your
model on a pre-built or a custom
container for operations monitoring
debugging and troubleshooting cloud
operations suite offers all the tools
needed to keep track of the resources
and applications
when it comes to security understand
that security in cloud is a shared
responsibility google cloud offers the
inherent infrastructure security and the
tools that you would need to protect
your application data and your software
the data is already encrypted at rest
and in transit you can also bring your
own custom keys for encryption too
for data loss prevention and protecting
pii information you have dlp which helps
mask and tokenize sensitive data in
bigquery cloud storage or even
on-premises
for user authentication you have cloud
identity which checks if the user is who
they say they are and for authorization
you have cloud iam where you can define
who has access to what security command
center continuously monitors your google
cloud environment for visibility into
the system discover vulnerabilities
detect threats and show that so you can
take actions on them
there are lots of other security
features that i did not dive into here
but go ahead and play around when you
create your own project we just took a
tour of most of the google cloud
services for an example application
foo.com we looked at some services for
networking compute
storage
databases
data analytics machine learning
security and operations there is
definitely a lot more to explore but i'm
confident this will get you started with
the right background
now it's your turn encourage you to sign
up for a free trial and follow this
tutorial yourself